bien tout le monde sait squeeze qu'est
ce que c'est que ça là encore ça va et
aujourd'hui attention se retrouve sur un
jeu qui a fortement concurrencé gta 5
lors de sa sortie vous allez très vite
comprendre
ah ah voilà ça me fait plaisir on se
retrouve sur un simulateur deux cuissons
voilà ils n'ont pas été foutus de
retirer ce week en plein milieu mon
écran et en fait cet homme est un grand
bruit et quoique attendait j'aimerais
bien à ok donc en fait en spammant la
touche espace s'excuser ne se transforme
en boîte de nuit n'ont pas ou sur les
instructions n'y a pas un post it away
[ __ ] donc la corde au campus il
cuisine sur des brûlures la mecque à
comment cuire un gâteau ajouter les
ingrédients et nomme voilà non moi c'est
lucas a les blagues nulles
on y va c'est parti donc déjà la
boutique de cet homme est un pur échec
celui de zéro client mais bon quand même
faire son petit gâteau quand ça joue
non non là on doit juste que je en train
de faire l'amour à une étagère
oh oui fait du bruit ce soir on peut les
joindre
ah oui un peu plus que les jours on peut
le dire haut on dirait une sorte de
planche en forme demain quoi ce pas les
bras ah ok donc ça c'est pour fermer
tous les doigts en fait c'est exactement
comme ça je ne suis là tort mais en
version nue l'élan que j'aimerais
cuisine et non ouais tu le dois patafix
bonjour et c'est quoi ce bros 1 quel mec
peut se gratter facilement quoi moi
j'aimerais bien prendre le sucre à 20
jours attendait de taffetas hockey non
non arrête je te caresse sucre reste
avec moi reste d'accord une sorte de
limite fait c'est une sorte de guitare
il s'était embouti
ou à tout [ __ ] dedans avec moi c'est
pas le beurre ça va être une très très
bonne idée
je n'écrase pas le beurre prend le nom
lâche le saladier lâche [ __ ] ok oui
c'est bon première étape de fête pour
fêter ça ça ma gauche il fait super up
oui/non farine
je te rattrape comme ça au nom anne on
fait ça traverse de d'accord j'ai cru
que la femme qui tombe mais en fait pas
du tout yes et maintenant jeunes farine
tu des non tu n'as pas le temps de faire
partie du gâteau et y ait un nom le
beurre ils s'envolaient [ __ ] wiki de
la farine elle va par terrain ça c'est
de manière immédiate aux plats au revoir
jeunes farine at home et carmaux besse
ii j'aimerais pas qu'il met une claque
de la taille de ses mains
personnellement le beurre il s'échappe
et où mon gars couet est collé contre la
vitre
ah non on est d'accord il vole mais j'ai
mis trop de farine failli mettre 100 g
robben s'était qu'un s'il te plaît jeune
beur peux-tu retourner dans le saladier
mais attention sinon c'est le doigt tu
l'auras pas aller avec moi je le prends
[ __ ] sûrement pas en faisant des
choses comme ça s'il te plaît c'est le
pouce qui te bonjour je suis un robot
j'aimerais prendre ce beurre on va
prendre le saladier on va les chercher
le beurre il est ou non mais bon voilà
le gâteau est prêt messieurs dames des
boîtes mais non renvoi de gâteaux
étagères et cette chanson est abominable
j'ai coupé au montage mais écoutez ça
j'ai une très bonne idée vous inquiétez
pas au con le truc souffle avec armand
brunstattois bien ok le gâteau va être
prêt en version un peu simplifié mais va
être prêt et maintenant bon bah voilà
le gâteau est prêt qui en veut ne tombe
pas je suis là avec mes mais dès le 4
mars de rattraper bon il manque un
gramme non mon gars yes yes
geof s'est alors passé le plus gros
examen de toute ma vie quoi on va passer
aux oeufs ou cassent pas la coquine et
rien de bahia pas de problème aux ça
marrant je voyais un bizarrement non
d'accord donc dans ses yeux il y avait
des oeufs déjà cuits d'accord qui est
néamoins tintin c'est affreux comme je
[ __ ] le sucre le sucre le sucre
associés mois soit ça cool et ça de g
d'accord donc pour nadja be 3 kg
j'espère que personne dans l'accueil des
diabétiques ya pas de queue pardon non
on a dépassé odieux ou au dessus tout un
sapin gâteau parfait mais on s'en bat
les steaks
attention attention le beurre est à nous
non non non ce temps je supplie bug pas
mon gars c'est l'heure de le mettre
non je vais tout lâcher ça fait un gros
bordel dans un jeu où à l'abri en eau
dans le beurre il aimait gaffe aux
blessés de s'enfuir y tout genre je suis
dans la farine
ok on est prêts on est pris en étau en
plateau avec le saladier de manière
évidente
oh mon dieu oh mon dieu on a accompli
beaucoup plus dingues de toute notre vie
mais mon gâteau pu tailler un gâteau
j'aurais jamais le gâteau en fait c'est
juste peyrens à l'aider dans un fourré
terminé qua non non à red bull est comme
un chat les une porte
nous y retournons aux jeunes beurs tusa
priés de ne pas échapper un sahara au
mignon alors oui
non mais c'est quoi cette barre à gauche
qu avec 40 days for b revient labeur
bird tu aimes la fine d'accord donc ça
c'est la farine et répété reprenant le
tube ya en fait des milliards de tonnes
de farine ça ne s'arrête jamais il
accueille sur son index est une sorte de
grande beauté et la hausse il en a
ramené dans mon gars en forme de
triangle en plus y'a pas une sorte de
clients à cacher où sont les clients je
suis bouleversée
tu vas perdre au bar c'est normal ok à
neuf qui séparaient au courant mais se
coupent absolument rien du tout par
contre quand je fais des gâteaux avec
obama makes est très utile
j'en ai marre de ce qu'est ce que c'est
que ça donc j'ai plus de salades et
qu'est ce que tu fais janov si vous
pensez que nous guident nos salades il
est peut-être un ok d'accord donc là
c'était la plus grosse déception du mois
et le grand retour de patrick au cirque
sont nouveaux numéros traversent les
grilles de four avec tam à droite
patrick est de retour pour du gros
incroyable il fait de la télékinésie
mais uniquement sur une porte de four
j'ai déjà tellement tout fait que le
seul truc j'ai pas fait c'est votre paix
doit dans un paquet de sucre le trou le
trou aux régions peu plus quant à dès
que je fais un truc ça disparaît vous à
tous mes voyages ainsi déjà fin de cette
incroyable cours de cuisine et c'est
vrai que ce jeu était vraiment
indépendant pour le coup il y avait pas
énormément de contenu en dehors
peut-être un dlc
j'espère que maintenant vous savez tous
comment cuisiner un gâteau et vous savez
aussi que dans les deux se trouvent des
zones déjà cuits donc il est utile de
l'hérault cuir on se trouve dans une
vidéo
ciao tout le monde pis ce jeu quoi me
regarde moi ça j'ai un moignon la [ __ ]
et
m